no it's so it's just dope to see man for
you like
uh have you felt cuz I I can only
imagine when you're a part of something
so big like you were and you you
voluntarily walk away mhm
um while trying to build your own [__]
there has to be some time whether it's
subcon ious or not and and I I don't
really take you as the type of person
like second guess yourself but you can't
help but be like a a normal human being
who goes through normal human emotions
was there ever any point in time where
you you know either one second guest
leaving NE or two
um did you feel like it was just a a
really hard uphill battle to try to get
over kind of being Jesse from the nek
boys as opposed to being Jesse from [__]
hole Jesse from Sunday like yeah I
mean it's kind of two big Parts
obviously it was like such a long thing
to do so it wasn't I did have I
obviously had the feeling of like should
I do this should I not because it went
on for 2 years you know what I mean so
it did happen and while that break
happened this happy Dad things going
[__] Bonkers yeah and you you owned a
piece of happy Dad right yeah yeah so
you're you're obviously I mean happy Dad
is [__] everywhere it almost feels
like it's like bigger than anything now
that those guys are a part of so I can
only imagine like like you said like
you're you're kind of like damn like
like I think that's just a human nature
thing to just be like is I mean not to
say necessarily second guessing yourself
but definitely like kind of assessing
what's going on like did I make the
right move and obviously you're in the
middle of negotiating a buyout I'm
assuming yeah um and I don't know how
much I can talk on it but
that like happy Dad full send milk
everything that was happening in that
time everything was being negotiated so
it was like there was a point where it
was like is this like leaving everything
or is this leaving some or what does
this deal look like and [__] so
that's why it was so big right obious
happy dad's massive it's like super
massive and I think yeah walking around
walking away with happy Dad is massive
and secure for me so wait do you still
own a piece of happy Dad yeah yeah
yeah we're we're sleeping good now we're
good so well I know who to ask to borrow
uh money for uh any sort of clothing
venture or Venture in general or if I
want to go get tugged off somewhere I
said Jesse yo cash at me 80 you got it
bud that's crazy there's a podcast clip
of me talking about that already where I
like said about I don't know it like
went viral as it's like I you know viral
a couple million views but of me talking
about how I sold the company but I kept
happy Dad
and it was so funny how that was
connected to so many people that I could
tell saw that and called me and started
pitching me all their
Ventures and I'm like I'm not that rich
bro like chill out also like dude [__]
off like yeah like I know you saw the
YouTube short and all but like you know
go [__] yourself like everyone wants to
go for lunch all of a sudden you're like
are you pretty like involved or you just
kind of no completely disconnected just
just get your check yeah shout out to
you man yeah it's that you're you don't
drink anymore but you own one of the
biggest Seltzer brands in the world it's
wild and then I've never tried it that's
[__] even more wild yo I
know wild that's wild because you had
already left cuz I remember watching
them go and do the tasting and you
weren't there yeah wow I know
sick that's so sick [__] weird yeah
it's crazy like I I I own something I've
never tried so you're like yo that's
crazy have you had any
and you know like I think that you you
spoke about it I don't think you ever
were like the type of alcoholic in which
like my uncle or some of my family
members are where like you're like
physically dependent on alcohol to get
through your day and if you were to get
off of it you go through withdrawals and
maybe end up in the hospital but you
were drinking a lot you were partying a
lot it was your lifestyle have you
gotten to any sort of point where you
were vulnerable where you thought about
having a drink at all yeah definitely
not but not in a negative way more I'm
not that's why I didn't want people to
think you're like relapsing cuz I don't
think that like I don't look at you as
like the guy who's like I'm sober 3
Years bro like I got my chip I'm going
to meetings I don't even say sober
anymore cuz I me's also don't drink I
just don't drink yeah and and honestly I
literally only did it cuz my mom said to
me one time she was like you don't want
to be the guy that can't have a beer and
I knew that it was more of a lifestyle
change I just had to get out of that
lifestyle where that was a part of my
[__] job every day and I think that
I've accomplished that and I feel
healthier and all this [__] so it's been
crossing my mind um just like how long
it's it's weird it's like it's such a
streak now that it's like weird to break
that seal and to be honest I'm a little
worried about how it'll make me feel
like cuz the last time I had like a
couple drinks I like made my head all
[__] up I [__] I don't know it
screwed me up so like the very last time
I drank so I don't know it actually like
scares me a bit to have a drink but
maybe that's good do you miss like beer
the most honestly maybe a cold beer but
maybe it's just like going over for
dinner and yeah having a glass of wine
feeling a little loose yeah like a
little like social drink you know yeah
yeah that makes sense I I guess if you
were going to break the streak you
should break it for the company that
you're part owner of yeah I would
definitely have a happy day yeah for
sure the best flavor by the way fruit
punch and I don't even think it's close
I think it's fruit punch and then I
think it's the death Road
grape I heard a lot of people saying
that grape one's great and then it's Pro
I'm not going to going to lie the first
like pack that dropped I think I only
liked one of them really I think I only
like I haven't had the banana one but I
do love fruit punch is fire really yeah
fruit punch if you're going to break the
streak you got to go fruit punch I got
to send you a case here man I didn't
know you drink it oh yeah yeah yeah
we'll get you some might uh you know I
opened a nightclub in Scottdale and uh
we carry happy Dad I didn't know that
yeah I'll check it out yeah it's a
hip-hop club obviously it's it's it's
not like the Scottdale spots you guys
usually go to that have happy Dad but we
are cracking we just had the baby we
just had sexy red we just I mean it's
it's lit but we do have happy Dad we
carry happy Dad so I've tried them all
but we I think we keep the grape in
stock the grape and the fruit punch
really yeah yeah I wonder how many
[__] stores and clubs and locations
dude it's crazy cuz it's everywhere cuz
I mean I'm sure as you know like when
you guys for I mean and you weren't
necessarily heavily involved but you
know it is your company part of it mhm
and when happy Dad first dropped it was
like a real mission to find it like if
you found I remember the liquor store
would be like dude we can't like we'll
get like 20 cases in and they sell like
right away to like one guy yeah and it
was like what the [__] I'm sure that was
all designed by Kyle like that's where
he's a genius like he just created the
Demand right away made it Limitless it's
almost like a drop style alcohol well
that's what they were doing where it be
like hey this location in Orange county
is getting thousand kids outside there
like kids but 21 21y olds man 21 year
olds of course I'm going to have to be
annoying and take a piss real quick go
take a piss you want to walk him over to
take a piss sorry about that man no
you're good all right we're
back all right my bad the piss has
commenced the piss has commenced um yeah
uh I I think like I think we were
talking a little bit just kind of about
like the process um
obviously uh shout out to happy Dad if
you were to have a drink we'd
established that it would be a happy Dad
you got to try your own [__] 100% um how
like I always wonder when you own a
company like that cuz like I'm part
owner of a nightclub I have certain like
ways I get paid out do you get paid out
quarterly do you get paid out yearly is
it by annually like I think it's uh
yearly but it's
mostly I don't even know how that all
[__] I haven't dove into it too much but
it's more of just like that [__] sells
one to [__] that's more sure it will
yeah that's yeah know you're banking on
the cell cuz the cell's got to be coming
eventually even if it's like not anytime
soon like it feels like like the goal if
you're like an upand cominging alcohol
company is to get it super popping and
then sell to like a bardi or like one of
these big dogs that yeah anheiser Bush
or something and just cash the [__] out
I have a feeling that that was the the
motion I don't want to speak for anyone
but I think they're seeing how well of a
job they're doing it and they're like
maybe this is a 10year plan maybe this
is like they're going to go for it
they're going to try to be like
Budweiser or like I get it I mean I mean
or white white what's what's the other
one white CLW white claw yeah what's
yeah I mean they have taken that market
share for sure man